the jogan experience I've had multiple
ocean scares now like the one the ones
where you're like crying on the beach
well no just that like in the moment I
keep telling myself don't panic Don't
Panic Don't Panic you know and uh one I
one I remember was in Hawai where we
rented a a Jeep and we were like what we
want to go see something you know so
they tell you oh take this road and and
it takes you to this single road that
goes up where there used to be volcanoes
and we come up on this beach and they
had mentioned the beach but not really
too much about it and so when we parked
I was like I love the ocean water I'm
going to get in the ocean you know so I
get in the ocean and I remember that
going in the beach into the water was a
decline right so like you go down and I
was just like knee deep in there about
to and and I was like man this current
is pulling back hard like really hard
and I kind of take like a step back and
I I feel myself going further down a
decline
into the ocean right and when I I I
decide to get out I have to really push
hard like all legs like boom boom like
run like you're running up a hill to get
out and I was like that was [__] a
wave hit you
there WWE wrestler they tell me though
when I get back to the hotel they go I
go yeah we took it I go that that uh
that beach was that was a little scary
they go did you get in the water and I
go yeah and they go oh you can't get in
that water like you'll drown in that
water no one did you notice there was
nobody swimming there I go yeah I
noticed I thought I found a [__] you
and don't tell you they didn't tell me
they're like do not swim in that water
they're like you can't swim out of that
if you would like they're like if you
would swam 10 ft in they're like you're
just gone oh my God and like the Panic
you feel especially in retrospect cuz
you remember the feeling of being like I
think I'm stuck here you know I think
I'm stuck right now F Simmons saved a
lady in Thailand really what yeah
someone was drowning and Fitz Simmons
swam out and saved them really yeah I'm
pretty sure it was Thailand somewhere
crazy like that yeah he's on vacation I
might have made up
Thailand it doesn't sound like a place
Thailand no he would go he's a world
he's a Hawaii guy he surfs in Hawaii
wherever it was fit Simmons went in the
ocean and saved a no [__] yeah I saw my
dad save a lady a scary in a resort that
was at the bottom of the pool just
laying at the
oh my god when I was like 9 years old it
was like Father's son he took me this
Resort and there's a slide you ever go
on a slide where the water that comes
off the slide that like so in other
words like like when you hit the water
it's like high impact you're like holy
[__] and it pushes you down I'm 9 years
old so this is many years ago and I
remember like I could swim I was on swim
team like as a little kid but I remember
being like [__] that is powerful like it
pushes you down right and you just swim
up and we're all people are you know at
the resort and then look down and my dad
swims to the bottom of the o to of the
pool and pulls up this lifeless body and
then they do CPR and she came back ho
shut up [__] and they would write
letters to our house for years she was
19 oh my God she wasn't a little kid did
you see the guy oh my God the
snowboarder upside down when the random
skier comes by just sees us snowboard
sticking this far out of the snow Yeah
is this the one where
and the guy was buried under the snow he
goes what the [__] he stops go he saved
the guy's life randomly is this is this
separate have you seen the footage where
the guy's wearing the GoPro I've seen
that right and then he's like into like
a
hole that you can is visceral that feel
like oh my God and then he's just like
we'll see what happens obviously he got
out because there's footage but when
you're watching that you're like oh my
God you could just fall in there forever
and apparently that's something that
happens tree Wells that's something that
happens so this guy just Falls and then
watch this
bro what I know Bert's feeling this no
I've had a couple experiences like this
he manages to stop himself what the [__]
how the [__] do you get out of that how
the [__] do you get out of that [__] the
skis how he get out of that it's over
Joe but no he's he's out no they they
had to I think I've read read about this
they had to get search and rescue he had
to hang out down there for a while
search and rescue had to come up and one
of GPS track so lucky that he stopped
right there but the way he he right here
he's not flailing he's like putting his
arm and his ski out to try to like so
this guy was able to keep some composure
as this was happening which is like kind
of the craziest part oh my God so this
is the snowboard that's buried upside
down so this guy just sees that little
blue piece bro just random this happened
to me ski right over him yeah he I mean
he easily could could G there's not much
blue soft snow he's in a tree well is
what it is so the tree Wells uh uh it's
really soft soft snow so if you get
stuck in a tree well you are [__]
dead a lot of people die in tree Wells
God damn yeah I'm thinking get one of
those GPS thing we went uh snowboarding
in matorn h skiing and the guy put a
beacon on us and the first thing he said
he puts Beacon it's like four feet of
powder and he says uh this is so we can
find the body and I was like what he's
like you might fall into a crass or an
avalanche so we put the beacon on to
find the body
got that feeling this happened to me
that feeling is terrifying this this
guy's like thank you good we get you out
here in a sec
okay he Panic the Panic he knew he was
feel Panic watching the Panic so what
happens is like what happened to me in
the when we were H skiing is I fell face
forward in powder I and I just I'd never
snow skiing snowboarding in powder
fouret of powder is very different than
snowboarding it's like you have to have
your bindings reset you have to really
know how to ride the powder
and and I could not turn right and the
guy told me he's like don't go within 5T
of my tracks stay within my tracks so
the whole time I can only turn left cuz
at the time I really wasn't that good of
a snowboarder and but I could snowboard
but not in powder and so he's going like
this and all I can do is go left and I'm
just going off the track oh no and I'm
[__] panicking we're but by the way
we're like 13,000 ft 14,000 ft it's very
little oxygen I'm gassed I'm fat I'm
hung over the day after the national
championship that we went to so we had
eaten Edibles it was like day after that
it was it was the day after that I flew
to [__] I flew to Switzerland and
immediately landed and went hell skiing
I don't remember that and so no no no
when we went to Florida State versus
Alabama 2013 yeah 2013 so all of a
sudden I go to turn cut right and I
catch it my nose and I [__] go face
for in the snow and at first I'm like
fine I push my arms in and they just do
not not touch anything it just goes like
this and now Snow's impacted on my face
so I can't really breathe and I I'm
first of all I deal with panic but Panic
hit kicks in immediately and I'm like
this is why I have the [__] beacon on
and so I try to clear the snow out of my
face but I'm like pulling all the
muscles in my back trying to turn over
and then the guy just comes up behind me
grabs me on the back flips me over and
he goes you should see your sound guy my
sound gu is upside down skis kicking
upside down in the snow and we just got
the [__] out we got on a helicopter and
got the [__] out I was like this isn't
safe